[Music]
it is a very exciting time here at our
show we are gearing up for our special
occupy conan episode this is real yeah
here's how it works we posted a special
best of episode online and we're
allowing you the fans to pick one or
more clips from that episode and
recreate them from scratch okay
we'll take our favorite entries and sew
them together into one groundbreaking
program that will air in our regular
timeslot instead of this show we're
gonna show what the fans made we've
already received some really great
submissions from live-action to
animation to stop-motion the entries
have been stunning very creative stuff
here's just a tiny taste of some of the
submissions so far I don't see that you
would look at it before picture and say
oh my god I'm so good we gotta do a show
in like five minutes
get up we gotta get out there come on
get up what's the problem
Conan you look awful
that comes from the heart
and you look great don't change it say
[Applause]
thank you thank you we're gonna use all
my techniques why are we doing this in a
bathroom the most dangerous place to be
in especially the evening use this as an
extension if we have to be your sloppy
duck techniques okay
[Music]
[Music]
very creative stuff so there is still
time get involved get inspired and make
a recreation of your own and don't
forget the fan who submits the best clip
is going to win an all-new Volkswagen
Beetle convertible just go to team
koco.com
slash occupy conan for all the details
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]